on the deserted streets of Bogota
they've become familiar figures backpack
wielding couriers on bicycles delivering
food or medicine to lockdown Colombians
most of them here or Venezuelan migrants
who say they have no alternative by
risking exposure to the coronavirus the
Raima Gomes a mother of four says
contagion is always on our mind but
since her husband lost his job staying
at home was not an option it's not easy
to go out and expose yourself to the
virus especially when you have kids
waiting for you when I get home I need
to take full precautions wash change
clothes before touching anybody trying
to be safe means context with customers
have been reduced to a minimum yet there
may be a bright side people who look
down on them as unskilled migrants
now say they're essential in the fight
to control the virus I received messages
on the app saying that we are heroes
like the doctors or the policemen I was
a nurse back home one year short of
becoming a doctor so I feel what I am
doing is not all that different from my
passion
helping others it motivates you delivery
services had already become a lifeline
for Venezuelan refugees across the
continent but as Latin America hunker
down thousands of lost their jobs with
delivery orders spiking so has the
number of recently unemployed migrants
moonlighting as couriers there are now
25,000 people working as delivery man
here and the company says they have a
waiting list of another 45,000 people
none of them receive health insurance
for their work and exposing themselves
and very few seem to have it no no the
companies don't offer insurance
I'm here with God's blessing Benny
Mendez says that at times he receives
masks and hand sanitizers but that he
has to buy most elements on his own
reports that in the United States more
than 40 grocery workers have died after
catching the virus worried him but he
says the issue is one of survival one
way or the other it's a blessing to
simply be able to go out and make some
money we all live with what we earn on a
daily basis no work means no food even
when working means putting yourself at
risk with little or no protection well
Allison Doren piatti joins me now from
Bogota it does really beg the question
after your report Alessandro what the
delivery companies are doing to protect
the careers yes rappy and I food which
are the two largest app delivery
companies in Latin America have turned
their offices into care centers where
these riders can go to get their
backpack their bikes their clothes
disinfected but from what we understand
it's very difficult for them to do it at
least on a daily basis which is what the
companies suggest they do because for
example here in Bogota there's only one
office is way in the north of the city
so it's too far away for many of these
worker to go all the way there to get
this disinfection we also understand we
put this question into rugby the largest
the company here in Colombian they said
that they're tapping into their revenues
to import hundreds of thousands of masks
and gloves and other protective elements
for the riders but they're saying
they're having a lot of difficulty doing
that but they're working on it and we
understand that in some cases they went
to the largest plaza where these riders
gather to distribute some of these
elements in any case though these riders
say that they're better off than the
great majority of the Venezuelan
migrants here in Colombia there are
almost two million of them and you might
remember that last week we reported on
the fact that many who haven't
able to make any money at all since
March 25th when the lockdown started
here have been in many cases evicted
from the rooms and small apartments
where they live often they have to pay
this daily and they haven't been able to
do so and so thousands have started to
walk back to Venezuela even if they fled
the economic devastation there they're
now saying we're better off back home
where the rest of our family is and
where at least we we have a roof since
in Colombia there's nothing left for us
to do and there's also the issue that
the government and the district here of
Bogota have really been able to do much
for them because the situation is
already so bad for poor Colombians that
they're absolutely being left on their
own for the update Alessandra pietila in
Bogota thank you